representing the government this morning
Greg hands chairman new chairman of the
conservative party hello to you Mr hands
thank you for joining us good morning
congratulations on your new position
uh what are you going to do to help
these people surrounding me this morning
well look we already have on our way um
um Aid First Responders for
um search dogs these have been directly
at the request of the Turkish government
obviously I've just seen your report and
the horrific scenes and our hearts go
out to everybody who's been affected by
as you rightly point out okay this uh in
terms of this earthquake happening at
such a
um such a challenged part of the world
uh Syria the Turkish border I mean it's
a really terrible uh situation and in
many ways a terrible place for this to
actually happen but we are responding
we'll respond to any further requests
from the Turkish government in
particular to provide assistance from
the UK
uh what was the delay in sending the aid
we've sent the aid as soon as we can in
direct response to the Turkish
government request uh it's on its way at
the moment I think it may be about to
arrive this morning
yeah I think it arrived actually about
one o'clock yesterday but it was delayed
it should have arrived the day before
minutes matter in circumstances like
this do you know why it was delayed I
don't have though the facts of the uh
the length of time uh but we all I know
is that we have responded directly to
that request uh from the Turkish
government We Stand ready to provide
more assistance should further requests
come through
are we sending uh anything else
are we sending any help we've sent as I
said 76 people Four Dogs We Stand ready
are we sending anything else
as I said we're we're going to respond
to uh requests from the authorities uh
from the Turkish government uh we stand
ready to do so as soon as we get those
requests coming in
what about financial aid
well we already provide of course a lot
to the regional one of the biggest uh
bilateral donors and particularly
um to uh Syria uh I think that it will
be something that would have to be
looked at in the round
um as and when requests are coming for
that assistance
you know I'm going to ask you about the
foreign aid budget should be 0.7 of UK
GDP that's certainly uh what it was
under David Cameron's regime he
introduced it it continued we have
reduced that to 0.5 percent
um do you have any idea what impact that
could have on people like these young
sorry sorry these youngsters are around
me if there was more financial aid
coming from the sixth most financially
structural power like the United Kingdom
well the UK of course uh shapes are very
favorably when it comes to our Aid
budget overall and obviously we have the
commitment to restore the aid budget as
soon as we're able the fiscal position
here in the UK allows us there's been no
reduction to Aid to the region we remain
one of the biggest bilateral donors in
particular to Syria the awful situation
that's been going on there obviously in
advance of the earthquake but this is
something the UK will be restoring uh on
the aid budget to get back to 0.7 but as
I said we do shape up very favorably
internationally in terms of the amount
of Aid that we are given
okay and when will we go back to 0.7
percent
well when the UK fiscal position allows
that uh as you're okay we've difficult
fiscal position uh here in the UK uh
we're getting to grips uh one of Rishi
suna's key priorities is to reduce the
debt uh halve inflation get that
position under control uh so that our
public finances can approve and allow us
to do that in due course
foreign
this year
well look uh I'll be would be right for
me to speculate on the future fiscal
position I know that the action that
we're taking we've got a budget coming
up next month uh but you'll have seen in
uh rishi's key five priorities laid out
last month the importance of the fiscal
position you know three of his five
priorities are reducing debt halving
inflation uh restoring growth there's
all a connection between those to
improve the UK's fiscal position to
allow us uh to spend more on the
people's priorities going forward
yeah we say that but as I said we're the
sixth richest nation in the world I'm
just going to move out the way you can
see this tented City behind me Nathan
can show you in a bit more detail these
people are sleeping in ice and snow in
Sub-Zero temperatures they've absolutely
lost everything that they had they run
out in their bare feet some of them some
of them from Syria and this is where
they're living they're relying on
countries like us we said that we would
give 0.7 of our GDP and we're not well
the UK as a CK is one of the biggest
bilateral donors uh the amount of money
that we give I say uh um uh shapes are
very favorably uh to International
comparators I absolutely understand the
situation there is there I know that
region well I've traveled in that region
uh before myself antakia gaziente
Aleppo these are places I know well I
and I can feel what people will be going
through at the moment but as I say the
UK our position uh is is is is very
favorable compared to many other
International countries and we are
committed to improve on that position
going forward
okay I just want to alert you to
something quite alarming actually it's
an app it's been called a snitch app uh
it's been released by the Turkish
government and they are calling on the
Turkish people the dis information
reporting service has been open to the
use of our people you can download and
Report the suspicious fake news produced
and spread about the earthquake disaster
to your phone
um what would you say to the Turkish
government when they issue stuff like
this well look I haven't seen the the
details of that app
um
well I'm not really able to comment on a
on a Turkish app uh here live on your
program what I will say is the UK is
watching the situation with the
earthquake the humanitarian disaster
that is unfolding that is why we've
responded to requests from the Turkish
government to provide the assistance
that we have provided and we stand ready
to provide more
yeah but this could put Aid agency
workers and journalists working on the
grounds illustrating what's happening
here at risk surely you must condemn
something like this well look I think
we'd have to have a look at the details
I haven't seen or heard about this app
I'm sure uh our Embassy in Anchorage way
to Mr hands forgive me for interrupting
you let me put it this way sorry we're
almost out of time will the British
government look at this
uh well look I think the foreign
Commonwealth office I'm sure will study
these reports uh we've got a very good
presence on the ground uh in our Embassy
in Ankara and I'm sure this is something
uh that will come to their attention uh
but in terms of responding to the
humanitarian disaster as I say the UK
has been responding uh we stand ready to
respond further as and when we get those
requests come in from the authorities
and from the Turkish government
Before I Let You Go uh congratulations
again on your new job surprise election
Victory coming from you do you think
well I think we're building uh towards a
general election next year we've
obviously got difficult local elections
this year uh the conservative party is
overall in good shape membership is
improving uh the financial position of
the party I think is improving uh I'm
definitely up for it I know Richie sunac
is up for it we're really looking
forward to taking on uh Sakia stalma's
unreformed labor party and the other
parties as well I think the conservative
party will have a really good story to
tell at next year's general election and
we're definitely looking forward to it